son père et son fils ont travaillé dans
la cordonnerie familiale elle est
maintenant à vendre sa femme al
thani
pour lui ça ne fait aucun doute le
coupable c'est le réseau express vélo
sur bellechasse qu'est ce qui en fait un
atelier au dessus il est complètement
puis j'ai fermé pour soulager résidents
et commerçants denis coderre promet de
ramener du stationnement ça prend une
fluidité assuré que les vélos puissent
passer mais pas au détriment de la
sécurité des gens puis on est capable de
vivre ensemble on n'est pas un petit
vélo on est pro mobilité on est pro
fluidité puis on veut protéger les gens
sur plus de la moitié du tronçon à l'est
de la 1re avenue la piste ne serait plus
que d'un côté de la rue bidirectionnelle
john mc cain a pas beaucoup en pense un
tube house la fa cup on est capable
d'avoir la moitié ça va être un hamas
une proposition qui fait bondir projet
montréal il est prête à sacrifier la
sécurité des montréalaises et des
montréalais des roses mentor de desroses
montois pour faire des gains électoraux
ce réseau là est un réseau qui sauve des
vies je la prends tous les jours
benjamin fall je m'en retourne chez moi
qui ai trop conne bellechasse plouay
mans c'est ce qui me permet de le faire
avec mes enfants parce que je prends
plus les autres pistes cyclables avec
mes enfants s'est passé l'âge
vélo québec salue la volonté de faire
mieux cohabiter les usagers mais craint
les impacts d'une telle promesse ça
reviendrait à ne pas appliquer les
meilleures pratiques et c'est
effectivement une question de sécurité
c'est à dire que on sait que les vizirs
actionnelle sont de façon inhérente plus
dangereuse que elle génère plus de
confier aux intersections
quant à la question de la fréquentation
si on se mettait à compter également les
rues qui ont moins de 150 passages auto
par jour on pourrait avoir des surprises
également
mais pas question pour denis coderre de
remettre en cause le rêve sur saint
denis
j'ai déjà des boîtes une dalle de ciment
mais ça me tentait pas de cela ici
mathieu prost radio canada montréal